>>> WELCOME BACK TO THE BIG
SUNDAY SHOW.
A YEAR AND A HALF AFTER SHARON
OSBOURNE WAS CANCELLED CALLED A
RACIST AND FIRED FROM THE TALK
FOR DEFENDING HER FRIEND PIERS
MORGAN SHE'S BREAKING HER
SILENCE WITH A NEW SHOW ON FOX
NATION SHARON OSBOURNE TO HELL
AND BACK.
>> I WAS THE LAMB THAT WAS
SLAUGHTERED THAT MORNING, AND
CBS DENIED RESPONSIBILITY ON THE
NEWS AND THAT'S BECAUSE THEY'RE
[INAUDIBLE] AND [ BLEEP ].
>> WE REACHED OUT TO CBS FOR
WHAT SHARON HAD TO SAY.
THEY REITERATED THEIR STATEMENT
FROM MARCH SAYING THEY FOUND NO
EVIDENCE THAT SHE HAD BEEN SET
UP.
>> YOU CAN GET GANGED UP ON LIVE
TELEVISION AND WHEN YOU GO TO
DEFEND YOURSELF AGAINST
ACCUSATIONS YOU GET FIRED FOR
CREATING A HOSTILE WORK
ENVIRONMENT.
THIS IS THE WORLD WE LIVE IN
TODAY.
>> I WANTED TO LOOK INTO THE
CAMERA AND SAY [ BLEEP ] AND CBS
TAKE THAT.
>> WOW.
THERE YOU GO.
YEAH.
THE GOOD THING ABOUT FOX NATION
IS IF YOU HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY,
YOU CAN SAY IT; RIGHT?
BUT GUY, ABOUT GETTING
CANCELLED, I THINK SHARON
OSBOURNE REALLY DOES EXPRESS A
LOT OF THE THEORY THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE FEEL EVEN FROM A DISTANCE
FOR PEOPLE WHO GET CANCELLED AND
TRY TO CLAW THEIR WAY BACK
BECAUSE IT FEELS ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE.
>> I HAVE TO SAY I WAS ON "FOX &
FRIENDS" THIS MORNING ON SET
WITH PETE HEGSETH AND SEAN
DUFFY, OUR SEGMENT WAS AFTER HER
INTERVIEW ON "FOX & FRIENDS" AND
PROMOTING THE FOX NATION SHOW.
SHE WALKED PAST ME AND I WAVED
AT HER.
MY COLLEGE SELF GOT EXCITED.
I HAD TO REMIND MYSELF DOING
SHOW PREP TODAY WHY WAS SHE
CANCELLED?
SO MANY PEOPLE GO THROUGH
FIRESTORMS LIKE THIS AND SORT OF
DROP OFF THE RADAR FOR A
WHILEFU
WHILE
FUL .
-- FOR A WHILE.
I WENT BACK TO READ THE SUMMARY.
HER DEFENDING A FRIEND OF
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST HIM BECAUSE
OF HIS CRITICISM OF MEGHAN
MARKLE.
IT TURNED INTO THIS WHOLE THING,
SHE THINKS SHE'S SET UP.
I THINK THAT MAKES SOME SENSE.
SHE'S OUT OF A JOB FOR THAT.
IT IS WAY TOO FAR.
GOING BACK FULL CIRCLE ON THE
SHOW, PEOPLE LEAVING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OR THE LEFT
WING COALITION, SOME OF IT IS
BECAUSE OF THIS KIND OF THING.
THEY ARE AFRAID TO SAY ANYTHING.
IT IS NOT A GOOD FEELING.
>> LET'S TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT
SHE HAD TO SAY THIS MORNING.
>> I DIDN'T WANT THAT TO BE THE
END OF MY CAREER.
I THOUGHT IT WAS UNFAIR.
>> GOOD FOR YOU.
>> EVERYBODY IS ENTITLED TO
THEIR OWN POSITION, THEIR OWN
OPINION.
SO IF IT'S YOUR OPINION, FINE.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BEAT ME UP,
FIRE ME, YOU KNOW, TRY AND
DESTROY MY LIFE BECAUSE OF THE
WAY I FEEL.
NOT THAT I FEEL ANYTHING ABOUT
IT.
>> BUT, YOU KNOW, JOEY, NOT
EVERYONE GETS A PLATFORM, RIGHT,
A MOMENT WHERE THEY CAN COME
BACK AND SAY THIS IS WHAT THIS
DID TO ME AND MY FAMILY.
>> OZZY OSBOURNE TOOK A BAT, BIT
THE HEAD OFF OF IT AND BECAME
FAMOUS FOR IT.
HIS WIFE TAKES UP FOR HER FRIEND
AND SHE'S CAN EL ED.
-- CANCELLED.
HE BITES THE HEAD OF A BAT AND
EVERYBODY LOVES HIM?
I'M BEING SARCASTIC.
THE POINT IS, CHRIS HANSON FROM
PLAYER OR THE SHOW WHERE ONE
DUDE DATES 40 GIRLS AT THE SAME
TIME?
I CAN'T REMEMBER WHAT IT'S
CALLED.
THE HOST OF THAT SHOW
>> THE BACHELOR.
>> SOMEBODY IS GOING TO PICK UP
ON MY HUMOR HERE.
THE HOST OF THAT SHOW GETS FIRED
BECAUSE ONE OF THE CONTESTANTS
HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN ANTEBELLUM
STUFF AND HE STOOD UP FOR HER
AND THOSE PEOPLE GET PUT IN THE
SAME CATEGORY FOR THOSE WHO DO
EGREGIOUS THINGS.
>> THIS AFFECTS US IN EVERY DAY
LIFE; RIGHT?
WE'RE SO SCARED TO SAY ANYTHING
TO ANYONE OUT OF FEAR OF
GETTING -- IN OUR OWN WAY
CANCELLED JUST IN DAILY LIFE AND
BEING MISUNDERSTOOD WHEN WE MEAN
NO HARM.
>> IT IS SO TRUE.
I JUST WONDER HOW LONG HAD
SHARON OSBOURNE HAD BEEN WAITING
TO SAY THOSE WORDS AND [ BLEEP ]
THEM ALL OUT THERE.
SHE WAS REALLY READY TO GO.
I MEAN, WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
ALICIA IS EXACTLY HOW I KNEW
THAT THE EXIT POLLS IN 2016 FOR
MY FATHER-IN-LAW WERE GOING TO
BE INCORRECT BECAUSE PEOPLE JUST
DIDN'T WANT TO HASSLE WITH IT.
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO TALK TO THE
EXIT POLLSTER AFTER THE VOTE AND
GET JUDGED BY THAT PERSON SAYING
I VOTED FOR TRUMP.
I KNEW THEY WERE GOING TO BE
WRONG AND THEY WERE WRONG.
IT IS A SAD PLACE TO FIND
OURSELVES IN I THINK IN AMERICA
WHERE WE'RE SUPPOSED TO HAVE A
WEALTH OF DISCUSSION AND IDEAS
AND EVERYONE SHARE THEIR -- YOU
CAN'T DO THAT ANYMORE.
YOU HAVE TO STAY IN LINE WITH
WHAT, YOU KNOW, THE WOKE MOB
THINKS OR ELSE YOU GET RISK OF
BEING CANCELLED.
GOOD FOR SHARON TO FIGHT BACK
AND TELL HER STORY.
>> I WANT TO HEAR WHAT ELSE SHE
HAS TO SAY AND WHAT ELSE SHE
WILL DO.
SHARON OSBOURNE TO HELL